hello everyone and welcome back to the
corner
corner finals quarter finals of the uh
feeder world cup uh 2021 it's uh sergey
karjakin
uh versus sam shanklin and yesterday
shankland won the game
uh and now uh karjakin needs to win to
bounce back and force tie breaks so it's
not an easy thing to do but he has the
white pieces and
well he's gonna do his best and this is
the first game we're gonna show
as uh today all of the games ended with
a well with a decisive
result and i don't know if i will be
able to cover
all four of them but i i will try so
without further ado let's check it out
as this is only the first of many so uh
sergey with
the white pieces opens with e4 as one
usually does when he needs to win the
game we have e6 going for the french
defense by shankland
d3 and d5 now striking in the center we
have knight to d2
uh and the knight to f6 we have knight g
to f3 and bishop to e7 so
this is all very very standard stuff we
have g3
and now uh usually uh players with the
black pieces just castle here but
shanklin goes a5 he wants to play a for
a3
and then again a lot of space on the
queen side and also maybe
you know stir some trouble here uh so
here we have bishop to g2
and uh a4 right away and now a3 not
allowing black to push
a3 and there is one game where castles
was played but here shankman plays c5
and it is now already as of move seven
that we have a completely new game
so uh let's see uh how uh sergey deals
with this we have castles uh
and now knight to c6 we have rook to e1
uh in the castles uh we have e5 now
attacking the knight driving more space
in the center
knight to d7 and now knight to f1
uh and b5 now here uh black grabbed a
lot of space
on the queen side and white needs to do
something about this so white will
either try to you know slow things down
maybe uh solidify in the center or
counter on the king's side which uh
sergey does he plays h4 now he wants to
play h5h6
and try and open up black's king side a
little bit because
like we said uh white needs a win in
this game in order to force tie breaks
so bishop to b7
uh and h5 now and much like black did on
the
queen side he also does on the king's
side so here we have h6
and bishop to f4 now so just continuing
development
the our e5 pawn is nicely defended now
so maybe you can even play knight to e3
so
momentarily the rook will not be
defending the pawn
but now everything is perfectly fine
here uh and here we have queen to b6
uh you might consider yeah you can't
really consider pushing anything on the
king side because that's what white
wants
uh white wants to keep the cl the center
closed and keep
nothing from happening on the queen side
and start some sort of an attack maybe
even sacrifice something queen d2 bishop
captures here
maybe we can play king h2 maybe bring
the rook over to the g file so that's
what white wants and basically to limit
the mobility of black's pieces so queen
to b6
by shankland and now queen to d2 saying
that okay now my rooks are
connected uh and i have a lot of
pressure here on the h6
pawn so rook f to c8 and now comes
g4 so now we're preparing g5 and we want
to bust open
uh black's king size uh king side with
uh queen back to d8
uh the queen will now uh will help out
with the defense because
here the black wing was good on b6 but
now when uh white
decided to push all the pawns in front
of the king now the queen needs to go
back
so uh knight one to h2 and now
rook to a6 preparing uh moves like rook
to b6 bishop to a8 rook to
rook to b8 we're gonna push b4 open up
the b file and then
try and activate our rooks along the b
file
and here we have kinked h1 uh going for
g5 right away
only favors black but i'm going to show
it to you because i know you guys
really want to see what happens if g5 is
played black will capture this and after
bishop captures we're gonna play
knight d captures an e5 that's that's
the stuff
uh even though it's defended plenty of
times the problem is uh the bishop here
is only defended by the knight
and the queen so now if you go for the
knight knight captures on e5
then we play uh bishop captures on g5
attack the white queen and now the white
queen
needs to do something about it so we're
gonna play f4 uh
block this and attack the bishop bishop
to h4 attacks the rook
rook to f1 and now we're gonna capture
on e5 for example f captures on e5 and
we have this position
uh where black is just better white's
king side is completely busted
and even though black's pieces are
currently kind of stuck here it's very
easy for black to activate with queen to
g5 where
you can you know push the pawn later on
uh it's
not going to be a problem uh another
thing after knight captures here you
don't have to go for knight captures on
e5 you could go for bishop captures on
a7
but even this doesn't yield all that
much knight captures on f3 first
with check knife captures queen captures
here and now again
it can only be black who's better here
so instead after rook to a6 we have the
com king to h1 clearing the g1 square
for for the white rook
uh we have b4 not uh doing any
preparation with uh you know putting the
rooks to the b
file rook to g1 and now comes
knight to f8 you could also consider
just capturing here for example captures
captures and then rook b6
also uh maybe something shankland could
play
but first he goes knight to the f8 and
now we have a captur sun b4 so white
doesn't wait for black to capture
c captures on b for n now d4 and this is
what we
mentioned yeah if you want to attack on
the king side you want to keep the
center closed
and uh you know it goes the other way
around if someone is attacking you on
the king side you want to bust open the
center
and you know have a have a some sort of
a counter attack so here at knights the
a5
and now the knight can come to c4 very
nicely with an attack on the queen
and uh uh uh goes for
the g5 move so here knights to c4
attacking the queen here
queen back to c1 and now h captures on
g5 with bishop captures and
now b3 and there were a lot of
possibilities here like
capturing the bishop might not be a
terrible idea
but the move b3 that shanklin played in
the game loses uh on the spot
uh but it's um not not an easy move to
find you know
even if you won't even pause the video
here and try to find how
white wins this position while i give
you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotif this
uh well incredibly difficult to move the
spot
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's bishop to f1
that's that's the stuff now we open up
the
the g file for the rook and we also pin
the knight here
as the rook is on a6 and here the
position is uh
incredibly complex and really really bad
for black but
just to give you an idea if black plays
something let's say b captures on c2
now we just play a bishop to h6 now
we're threatening to
capture on g7 and after g6 is played we
can simply capture here and if knight
captures now we play bishop to d3 and
already you can see that it's very very
hard for black to survive this
if king to h7 defending now we bring
more attackers knights to g5 with
check we are going to play bishop
captures bishop captures attacks the
queen
and if queen to f8 now we play knights
the g4 and again that there are simply
two
too many attackers going after the black
king and all of black's pieces are
here doing well doing absolutely nothing
another thing you could do for example
after bishop f1 if you don't want to
just play some like
b captures on c2 is you could eliminate
one of the attackers but it doesn't
really help
knight captures on g5 and now again what
are you going to play h6 is coming
so we might play knight h7 to challenge
the the knight here but
just queen to f4 now we're gonna attack
the f7 pawn
uh rogue c7 for example defending and
now knight captures king
captures c captures on b3 a captures and
now
rook captures on a6 bishop captures and
now knight to f3 and again
there are simply too many too many
attackers here for for black to handle
while all of black's pieces are here uh
not
not very active and there is really
there's really not an active move black
in play here so it's
really really a terrible position and
again h6 is coming
and black's position will simply crumble
so uh this was in the position
but it's uh it's not uh you know a move
you can calculate there are too many
sub-variations and you know
it's simply too too much so here we have
bishop captures on e7 first
clearing the g file for the rook a
little bit and now only after queen
captures an e7 now bishop to f1
but now it's a little bit different um
uh you you without the dark square
bishop uh
white's attack is not as powerful but
it's still a great great position so
here we have
a3 by black uh one might also consider
f6 or f5 those would be the moves that
would give black the the the best
fighting chance but in the game
a3 was played but this again just loses
on the spot
really really terribly so feel free to
pause the video for the second time
and find this incredible idea for the
white while i give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on
you know always looking for that
beautiful move that sacrifices something
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's of course
rook captures on g7 with check
and there's not much you can do here if
you avoid this you're just getting
checkmated on the spot
uh knight h7 queen captures on h7 will
be checkmate
so you have to accept this sacrifice
king captures and
uh g7 was played but now knight to g4
now going for queen to h6 and there's
really no good way to prevent
this uh there there's really no way to
prevent this so here
f5 was played and i was saying okay you
can maybe give queen to hd check maybe i
can escape somehow
but white now says i don't need to do
that now even though queen h6 is fine
here i can just go
for the black queen e captures and f6
alpha
so now you have to capture otherwise
you're going to lose the queen for
nothing so queen captures we have knight
captures and
now a captures on b2 attacking the rook
and the queen here but luckily we have
queen to g5 check so queen g5 check king
to f7
and now h6 you can't really uh go after
the rook if you capture the rook we're
just going to deliver checkmate here
so knight the g6 and now comes knight to
h4
again you cannot capture the knight here
if you capture it then again queen to g7
is checkmate
so you have to play something uh in the
game b captures on a1 was played
black brought another queen into the
game but now just queen to g6 check
king to e7 and now queen to g7 check and
here
uh shanklin was an incredible sport and
he allowed
checkmate to appear on the board he did
not resign here he played king to d6
and here uh sergey karjakin very very
happily played queen to b7 and
this is now checkmate so a very very
rare occasion where that we will see a
checkmate on the board between uh such
top-level players uh and it's always the
sign of a great
gentleman to allow checkmates to appear
on the boards because
chess is also a spectator sport and you
know um
newcomers and people who are you know
not that serious about just really enjoy
seeing checkmate on the board
and seeing here the black king
surrounded like this which would know
where to go really is a
nice uh you know not not not a bad way
to uh maybe end the day or start one
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh sergey karjakin bounces
back
and uh they will play tie breaks
tomorrow to see who will advance the to
the semi-finals of defeated world cup
2021
i'm not going to disclose the results of
the other games even though all of them
were
very very uh decisive but we're going to
cover more of them
so stay tuned so that's it i hope you
guys enjoyed it uh i would like to thank
psp aruslav
lubelski matthew benlit vlad lu studios
and
dario pavlovich for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
uh continuing the coverage of this video
world cup checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
uh thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day